[Music]
I believe you though I'm not new to the
game but oh you got this look at that I
already see the blood in there that's
cool has changed over the years I mean
these kids are really sharp and we have
a lot of students that come through that
just graduated and we can teach them
some of the nuances in the ins and outs
that they may not learn in school when
they first step in and crew to fix it
though sometimes I I see their eyes get
this big like oh there's no doubt they
get overwhelmed I mean it is Controlled
Chaos you get that look like I don't
know what I signed up for but I don't
think this was it and you have to kind
of pull them to the side and you have to
let them know you need to put your
blinders on and you only can deal with
one patient at a time so you really they
have to put them to the side because you
you want them to show up the next day
yeah
that's right
come on Leo you're a big boy today the
cases are stacking up quickly at Critter
Fixer including a box of abandoned
kittens hand delivered with care
it's okay baby hey how are you I'm good
how are you trying to see in a little
while those are the cutest kittens ever
tell me about these babies they have
been dropped off at the sheriff's
department and this one here was not
walking right the head keeps kind of
flopping okay I brought in three kittens
there was a box that they were put in so
I went ahead and picked them up and
brought them here to Dr Hodges two of
them look pretty healthy but this one
here I'm concerned it might have a
fractured bat hopefully we can see
what's going on with it the other two
seem okay all right sounds good how do
you think they are I'm looking at
everything about four weeks all right
let's see this baby here
[Music]
wanna pick up the skin and just kind of
look at the turtle and see how it just
stands up definitely tell me we're
dehydrated can you walk it out
different gate
it's so sad all right we're gonna make
you feel better be right back okay okay
it's okay on physical exam of these
three kittens two of them look pretty
normal how have I noticed some turkey
jerky movements with the third one also
I've noticed that this kitten is
dehydrated we don't want to put a little
IV in you I definitely need to get
fluids in this kitten because
dehydration can really be bad news the
liver starts to shut down the kidneys
start to shut down all these organs they
no longer functions as a unit and this
can be fatal we make a little blib we go
right up on the skin and we just fill it
up I know it's uncomfortable the body
will absorb that that's how we hydrate
kittens never got in this cat hydrated I
want to check out
jerky movements and do a walking test to
figure out exactly what's going on
[Music]
definitely on a different walk a little
exaggerating I'm gonna check his pelvis
okay this this kitten has been outside
and I mean there's all kinds of things
that could possibly have happened I mean
was this kitten traumatically injured
maybe got hit by a car so just the rule
out if there's any kind of fractures or
anything going on that I'm not seeing
externally I'm actually gonna go in and
take a few radiographs of this kid we
gotta do a picture but you gotta be
still I know that's kind of hard
everything is where it's supposed to be
all right nothing wrong with you on
x-ray but we may have another little
problem
so the x-rays looks fine oh good like
nothing was broke so what do you think I
am sure this Kitty is suffering from
something we call wobbly kiddie disease
cerebellum hypoplasia I've seen it right
the mother gets a disease called pan
leukopenia it passes on to the kittens
and pan leukopenia attacks the
cerebellum and it never develops that's
why they're wobbly they're kind of make
exaggeration because the function of a
cerebellum to keep them steady they
don't have it the good news is Stephen
walking in typically it doesn't get
worse they can be totally happy healthy
kids okay and it's you a lot of money
just tell the person just a special
Kitty
see if I can teach you how to eat when
you wean kittens and start trying to
teach them how to eat oftentimes once
you give the food near their mouth
they'll just start eating pretty quickly
that's right no no no no no no I haven't
cashed with wobbly kidney disease you
really have to take a little bit more
time kind of make sure you put the food
in your mouth or need it takes a little
bit of work let's let's work
here oh
look at that I knew you would eat oh
this was calling for Santa y'all got it
down okay it's not the most graceful
thing in the world but he's getting a
job done and he is right there they're
able to take in food I feel like we got
a really good chance for these kittens
to thrive and become healthy kitty cats
you're good to go see thanks thank you
so much
oh I know I'm glad nothing was fractured
but dealing with the the little wobbly
kiddie disease it's just going to take a
special kind of family that will watch
over them so we'll just have to find
them some good foster parents all right
guys let's go
we got sugar sugar and something sweet
sugar and cookies
how's it going how you doing all right
all right so who you brought today sugar
and cookies and cookies all right now
this is the first thing that you had yes
the first one they've been doing good so
far yeah they're real hyper and they get
into everything they can get into right
yes sir yes they do
I have two Fair their name is sugar and
cookie they get an awareness exam and
they also the raping shots I always
wanted a fair when I was younger now I'm
about to be 40 and I just love them they
very good with the kids they love them
until they get chased by them
that's sugar the sugar you know what you
sound like
good and let's take a good look here oh
that's a big home Ferris you know if you
hold them or you Scruff them and you let
them hang for some reason it kind of
puts them in this mode where they kind
of yawn and they're kind of like sleepy
I love it because they'll give you an
opportunity to be able to do a good exam
because they can spin they can get into
anything it'll be very difficult if we
didn't have that shrick you know that's
contagious right you're not supposed to
get on and we all start yawning in the
head shaking you notice there's a little
bit of debris here in this ear because
what I don't want to do is lead to the
ear infection yeah we probably need to
flush it out a little bit all right you
ready for your vaccine just a little
stick here let me say it's picky come on
out of here
I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah just go to
sleep same thing in that ear flush your
toes as well I'm over with everything
physically on exam look good except
those ears I want to get them clean now
but also I'm going to trim the nails a
little bit before you because they get
along there all right
on examination I saw that the ears were
a little bit dirty a little extra
cerumen in there so if we don't get them
cleaned out and it continues they have
ear infections which can cause a lot of
other issues neurological being off
balance or hematoma so it can be a very
serious problem not going to take very
much here tickles don't it yeah it's Wet
Willies today well we can see the
material that we're getting out of there
that can cause us some problems down the
road all right let's switch up here
there you go that's what I like right oh
yeah shake it out let's get these nails
here what's the fear number one
amusement park ride
the ferris wheel
did I get it good job the ferrets will
you're smarter than the average parents
sugar and cookies exam went great it was
a good spa day for them and you know I
got a pedicure manicure ears clean so
they're gonna be all good all right got
everybody taken care of any questions
you give us a call okay we'll do
everything looking good I feel the whole
it because their ears are so small you
really can't check them so now I know I
have to go get the ear cleansed I will
be back for another checkup next year if
I don't have to come before then
hopefully I don't take care of these
babies okay all right all right
no no no no no no no come on
come on dude take care of those babies
come on you know you want to go on a
little field trip lady the goat arrives
for her doctor's appointment kicking and
bleeding there you go girl you know Wars
up we're bringing in lady our goat we've
had lady two years now she's been quite
the interesting goat
she is a troublemaker we think lady is
pregnant we just want to make sure that
she's having a safe pregnancy and see
kind of how far along that she is it's
been about 30 minutes trying to catch
her gotcha we'll see what kind of babies
we got here lady to go is here today and
it looks like she's about to burst she
definitely looks like she's pregnant and
she looks like she's pregnant with more
than one kid oh girl yeah ghosts can
sometimes have twins and they can even
get up to as many as five but I think I
need to shoot an x-ray and see exactly
how many we have in there
let's see how many babies we got in here
I'm surprised at it unless you see that
nothing
wow that's strange I'm not saying
anything that's the door in this thing
yeah
tighter I want to see what's going on
here that don't make sense
you take X-rays you can see the outline
or the skeleton of the babies but I
don't see any so we're gonna maneuver
and make sure
we should see something here all right
you ready yeah
nothing again
I don't make sense
it just don't make sense I don't know
she means one more x-ray just to make
sure I'm not enough you got it dog
just one more shot but so far I'm coming
up here I mean I'm starting to believe
this gold is not pregnant and if this
goes not pregnant then there's something
else going on and I gotta figure out
exactly what it is
I mean I don't see no baby
it's always the end of the day so
I have no idea man I am shocked
it just don't make sense I'm on the
ultrasound
x-ray we'll look for the skeletons of
the babies but it takes about 40 Days
for those skeletons to form so it could
be early early pregnancy and the calcium
is not quite in the bones so we don't
see anything so I'm gonna do an
ultrasound and I'm gonna check for
Heartbeats
understand that see nothing
oh man I don't know look at what's going
on I thought for sure I would see a
heartbeat what you think about it she is
not pretty
let me palpate this album and see what I
feel
I mean little that is yes
oh wow let it go it's not pregnant that
really blows my
you can really feel a hard Mass on the
inside of that and doing uh have
patience I just felt something that
seemed like air but white ladies gassed
up it's still a mystery but we need to
figure this out because I'm sure it's
causing a lot of discomfort I did an
ultrasound so I shot the next Ray
nothing what what exactly that is insane
when I press that's what it is that is
strange let me grab a little blood run a
complete blood count and let's do
something okay so CBC or complete blood
count tells me if there's an increased
white blood cell count or if we're
fighting off an infection and on stool
sample lets me know if we have any kind
of parasites or if anything going on
inside of the intestine it's all gas
don't smell it you want to write in
um
can definitely be a serious issue but I
need to make sure all gases exchanges
are doing outside the clinic I got your
blood worked out let's go may have
pneumonia it's white blood cell count
already should be high of 19 we're
almost at 25 000. so we got an infection
I need to get a chest x-ray right now to
make sure we don't have any pneumonia
all right Emma you come in and thinking
it's just going to be a pregnancy easy
peasy and then you end up having a sick
coat let's see what we're working with
lady
what's that doc a lot of congestion
terribly bad
I see some pneumonia but luckily it's
not bad as I thought all right I'm
looking at the stew positive from
parasites as well we have parasites
causes some inflammation in the
intestinal tract with the parasites and
the pneumonia the GI kind of slows down
that gives more tense of fermentation
which produces more gas and all that is
what's causing the blue I ran a CBC and
we got an infection uh check the fecal
sample she has quite a few parasites too
oh wow and some pneumonia oh my goodness
so I'm gonna start this with no
antibiotics okay and I'm gonna deworm
okay okay all right so hopefully we can
get this clear this really could have
spiraled out of control but since we
have antibodies for the pneumonia and a
dewormer treat these Penske parasites I
think the prognosis for lead is really
good how long should it be before her
stomach kind of goes back down in the
next three days oh okay she's even
smaller than when she came in did she
have a lot of gas yes ma'am she did she
did
I'm glad that we brought her in because
there's no way we could know any of this
on our own pillow right here just
straight here it is it could be worse
and hopefully once we get her medicated
and everything she'll be good as me
she's pregnant with gas
oh is she gassing oh that is terrible
you just chilling on the table there all
right let's go let's go
crew fixes are here today with vet for a
day we simply just put some stuff out on
social media and said do you want to
come hang out with the Critter fixes and
learn what it takes to become a
veterinarian we got all these
applications in a few days from kids all
across the country so we thought what
better than to bring them all in at one
time have a full day of activity so they
have an opportunity to see myself see Dr
Hodges perform various tags as well as
our technicians it's our way of creating
new veterinarians
so cute representation matters
African-Americans aren't really
represented in the field we're like two
percent and we're here in this
profession being good example for that
next Generation you excited yes I'm
excited I want to help these pick up you
want to help them out well we gonna help
them out so we're gonna start with
neuter first everybody was seeing
surgery close up we've had them pass out
before so Harley gonna be the holder now
we get to and let them see what we
actually do not what they think we do
the older hour Jingle Bells right so we
pop both of them
you're about to see us with fur little
puppies but we also do some pretty grosy
things so anybody know what a cat spray
what that means
that's the end result yeah you're right
though we're gonna see who really wants
to hang with the critic so we're gonna
make our own surgeon the intestines
there that's our uterus we want to take
over his and the uterus out so that's
our ovary in our uterus that's going out
right there okay this is satisfying so
y'all gonna be ready to do the next one
you raise your hand no
Oh I thought she was raise your hand hey
T yes sir she just said oh y'all
y'all from play play
no telling no playing in here so we have
all hands on deck we have all employees
to help us out because they believe in
the same cause that we do when you
listening for hearts you also want to
make sure you don't have any heart
murmurs they know they're educating and
giving experience to their next
Generation how important it is before
the doctor comes it's urged up to get an
accurate weight and temperature they're
all here willing and ready so typical
exam I want to see how the heart's
beating so my next thing I'm just
getting it all comfortable trying to do
this all in one quick motion because
they don't like you open them up and
before they know it voila my hand is
down in there
doing anything very rarely because when
I come in the room I am looking at the
demeanor of the dog that tells me how I
want to approach this dog now I'll tell
you a cat is a whole another story
y'all still think y'all may want to be
vets what kind of vet would you like to
be
you want to work on giraffes yeah I love
giraffes are you ready to be a Critter
Fixer these kids are so smart they're
hopping right in my favorite surgery to
do bone surgery not into this right here
to be Hands-On nobody scared
right it all worked out though so can we
get JR us up here one of the moms she
said he's gonna love this because this
is his birthday so I was like let's get
him a birthday cake we have a happy
birthday cake for you
you want to open that so he could have
spent his birthday anywhere he wanted to
whatsoever and he did it with us that's
all right yeah
this is the amazing thing to surprise
him and tell him happy birthday you know
he started to tear up almost having me
tear up
this is what it's all about today I
think was a great day how many kids have
an opportunity to go and see surgery how
many have an opportunity to see
endoscopy and take a look down with the
scope inside it inspired them even more
to want to become veterinarians
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the Critter fixers answer a field call
to provide some head to toe care for a
pair of animals so George you know how
you go to the carnival like you got
young kids I'm sure y'all probably go
ride or ride my thing is to look at
animals I really like that DJ you know
we walked through I always enjoyed it
yeah I always try to ride a rise and
then we'd be looking at animals I won't
let you live your best life Willie
everybody has their Fair tradition like
what you get like your peanuts turkey
legs
apples yeah that's what I get well you
get everything like a garbage disposal
[Music]
is coming out here today to look at the
duck in a turkey we've used them for our
dogs and when we started the farm we've
been using them from them also we would
never take our animals to anybody else
and they have been a big help so what we
got to do Donald which is the male duck
we got and I just noticed him walking
different then we have a turkey the goat
and turkey buttered heads oh and then
Jenny's neck and her head like swell up
wow okay really concerned that it could
be something bad so we're going to start
all right bro I'll take Jenny to Turkey
I guess they'll leave Donald for me we
can go through that way all right we're
following you man this has been a full
day it was a lot of fun with the vet for
a day and dealing with the kids but
there's a lot in one day we have a
divide and conquer we gotta get back to
the clinic ASAP sometimes I wish we
could just clone ourselves yeah maybe we
could just say beam me up Scotty
and I can disappear somewhere else okay
all right all right uh-oh they got a lot
going on there you see that area now
we're getting a sword there yes that's
where their foot goes down he must have
got on something that was harder and it
caused it to have irritation right it
actually has what we call Obama put
where bummer food is is an infection of
the foot his left untreated now the
infection can invade and get in the bone
and then you're talking about having to
remove the foot so it can definitely be
serious so what we're going to do is get
this area cleaned up and get Old Donald
feel a little bit better this is
Betadine beta down solution yes sir
luckily with this bomber foot Joe caught
it in time normally I would have to cut
that area out but in this case I don't
have to do it clean up with Betadine or
and putting ointment on there hopefully
I'll get that inflammation and subside
we just have to figure out how can we
banish this thing to keep the pressure
off that area so it can get better what
I'm going to attempt to do is make a
little bandage I want to make it kind of
like a donut we got to kind of be a
little intuitive why are you leaving the
core exposed trying to raise this up
around the side so it touches the ground
before the that I don't want pressure to
be on the wound there because it'll
cause more trauma more irritation it'll
get worse no it's nice million dollar
bandage that Joy so I can continue to
clean it yes sir we're gonna soak clean
antibiotic ointment once a day and it'll
go away I can do that Donald Duck is
going to be fine we got the area cleaned
up we told the owner exactly what to do
then we're going to put doll in
isolation so that we're away from
everybody else so we don't bother the
bandage and they don't harass my Donald
Duck here not gonna be happy with us are
you all right Donald
oh that's what you think about me I'll
feed you in a little bit don't be too
mad Donald poor thing
across the farm Dr Hodges helps a turkey
whose injury has gone to its head nice
and easy
that's a little harder than Thanksgiving
huh yeah rule number one don't let the
turkey go
oh boy I got some bruising on your head
don't you I've never seen a turkey like
that before definitely scary so it
looked like we have a burst air set he
hit him pretty hard he did Jenny has a
huge air pocket on the head and
throughout the Aztec is located right
near the lungs and so what's happening
is this air has gotten caught up under
the skin so I need to get every bit of
air out because this could definitely
cause more damage to the air sacs and
possibly there I got you it's okay
let's see if I can let some of your air
out your air set for me man let me see
if we can release a little yeah oh there
you go
[Music]
I didn't know we just needed to tell him
to open his mouth
sometimes when you have a weird case
it's got to come up with a kind of a
weird solution so in this case it's got
to burp the turkey burp a turkey birds
have multiple air safes so when this Air
Bursts air actually goes all over the
body so you just gotta get that air out
of those places anywhere you can as I'm
doing this I kind of massage it and just
pushing the air out come on
do turkeys burp yeah I guess so
better I was able to massage quite a bit
of the air out of Jenny however that was
could have been still left yes above the
air sac to keep this problem from
reoccurring they need to get every bit
of air out I need to use a 12 gauge
needle so I can remove the rest of that
air yeah right there buddy air six here
so I'm trying to go down lower
here
how you doing bud
there is literally passing out of this
turkey almost
or a balloon start gently manipulating
some of the air out and kind of
deflating that balloon cool all right
here
so if it lights back up push it all the
way down I don't break the chest you got
it down pat all right there is not a lot
of meds you could do for Jenny over time
this [ __ ] correct itself and Jenny
should be fine if you ever get a knot on
your head you're gonna push it down I'm
gonna push it down
when air started coming out of the
turkey's mouth I was shocked I didn't
know that a turkey could burp I mean I
was scared that her skin was going to
explode or ahead so I'm glad that they
were able to squeeze the air out and be
able to treat it it has me feeling
wonderful you need anything else holler
at us you know how to get them yes and
we'll be here and blink of a it's not
the hottest thank you so much Frozen
thank y'all
[Music]
the British Virgin Islands any country
folks in the Brazil there's got to be
some country part of the version I mean
there is a country but we're not country
well somebody came to you and they say
man I'm feeding to go what is finale
my teacher taught me what finna was in
third grade we finna learn these
agencies
you could just say you're going
[Music]
doing a great job but we got a problem
he don't understand
that's a common word you are preparing
to leave right right that's right we had
to work on him yeah you don't like
cornbread oh I love cornbread what I
love cornbread you know it's not
cornbread thank you cornbread cornbread
say it again cornbread no cornbread
cornbread no no every day we're gonna
have to feed cows some of this Southern
terminology for sure he'll have this
Georgia 20. down to a science hey we
finna get him right he said let it roll
out don't say cornbread Jesse I want
some cornbread cornbread there you go
keep on hanging with him down here man
you're gonna be all right one day
we got Roscoe here Ross Roscoe has a
nice tumor yeah that's a pretty big one
not important is this the biggest number
ever for you definitely
we noticed Roscoe had a lump once the
lump had grown his personality started
to change and he was having trouble
breathing so we brought him here he
means a lot he follows me everywhere I
go I don't want to lose him
mom has gone to a couple vets who said
let's watch it but it is getting bigger
and bigger it's probably better to get
it off which thing not someone to go get
it out what it's very important that we
get this huge tomb on Roscoe golf ASAP
because it's impacting Roscoe's
breathing as well as quality life I just
don't know if it's cancerous or benign
once I get inside I definitely can come
up to a possible conclusion in your mind
you have to mentally like say okay I'm
got a mental picture how I'm gonna cook
how am I going to put this back together
but the beauty of it is I'm gonna be
right there yes yes that's the magic
pill right there Dr Porter is a new
veterinarian here she hadn't removed a
tumor quite this large so I'm gonna
glove up with her and co-pilot and help
her remove this huge tumor you ready
when you're removing the tumor this size
it's always been tense because you
removing this huge masses a quarter of
the size of this whole pit you don't
know if what organs is affecting if it's
very vascular meaning this term has a
huge blood supply and those Arters and
veins bleed since animal could possibly
bleed today I know it's okay
we gonna do everything we can to remove
this tumor in the safest way possible
all right doc I'm getting your cockpit
ready okay getting ready for you to fly
I'm ready it's all you Dr Porter yes yes
good job go down to here nice let's see
let's go on just a little bit more yeah
open it yeah a little bit more perfect
all right now you've exposed it
it's a big tumor very big
oh boy that is not a lot of Homer no how
are they
sucker's big cut there so now we pulled
this tumor out
look at that that's pretty big too man
that's an angry looking tumor oh wow
it sure is looking at this tomb it looks
like cancer to me it looked very very
angry which means it has a huge blood
splop it is hard to the touch and it's a
lot more dense than fat you may have to
do some cancer treatment I don't talk to
the owner about that yes you always
worry about tumors like this because it
could metastasize they get in the
vessels they can go and metastasized to
the lungs so I need to get this tumor to
a pathologist and have some tests done
to figure out exactly what's going on
all right we need to get this dog sewn
up good job Doc's just showing it up you
know this is the first huge huge surgery
I mean I couldn't be more proud if
you're watching someone up that looks
fantastic what you think doc would you
call it easy
hmm how about easy is the right word I
think you could have did this without
thanks for your faith in me but no I'm
glad you were here teamwork DreamWork
yes sir looking at this tumor it
definitely doesn't look like I was
hoping it would look if this dog does
have cancer cancer treatments have
definitely come a long way but for now
I'm gonna call the owner Lakeisha and
let her know that we got this tumor out
when Roscoe's recovering and doing very
well the good news your dog did amazing
I'm very happy with how it came out but
unfortunately though I don't think
that's a lipoma cancer is definitely on
my radar we just have to wait and see
what it is but I got some other things
that we could do if that's what it is in
the meantime first step is done and your
dog is doing well
foreign
yes
Clips the cat is itching to have his ear
checked out you know how old this baby
is he is 13 years old 13. let me take a
little peek feel her hair loss there I'd
have been scratching definitely got a
fat ear though don't we so we got a
hematoma eclipse is my cat I've had him
for 13 years he's the old man he's
crotchety but he's just a great cat I
love him a lot unfortunately his ears
swelled up and it just freaked me out
the older animals are the more things
can go wrong with them so I'm just
really nervous oh it's okay all right
baby if you didn't have any hematomas
but something is wrong with the ear that
makes them you know shake and flap and
then they break the vessels in the ear
yeah I think that Wilson's been shaking
his head and it caused a oral hematoma
where blood is trapped between the skin
and the cartilage of the ear the owners
see the hematoma but the problem is
really down in the ear
yuck oh man they're really inflaming we
got a combination of both yeast
infection and a bacterial infection
makes sense these ears they're inflamed
there's a lot of extra earwax or Saruman
this is exactly the outcome that I was
trying to prevent in the fairs sugar and
cookie both the hematoma and the ear
infection probably very painful for
clips and we need to take care of this
as quick as we can we definitely need to
surgically repair this ear
you're 13 we got to check you out to
make sure you're good for anesthesia
okay so take the baby back it's okay but
but Cliff is an older cat which
definitely put concerns on us having to
go to surgery we want to make sure
there's no issues with liver function
kidney function because the anesthesia
we give the body has to get rid of it by
those means so if we test those areas
and they're normal we feel pretty safe
going on anesthesia Clips blood work
looks all good doc all right let's go
okay you got everything good everything
I'm ready to get them down
let me get no ears really clean now they
really horrible or dirty
there's one step that we need to do
prior to going to surgery and that's
cleaning out those nasty disgusting ears
his ears are nasty it's like look at tar
in here but at least it's not my job
that's Jordan's job I'm gonna get one
more flush gonna be good it's important
to clean these ears because if we don't
start shaking our heads again in this
hematoma will reoccur and that's the
last thing we want to have to do surge
again on a 13 year old cat all right how
are we doing my heart sound good
so you can see what it's so here is real
fat there yes sir so we have to make a
decision we're all gonna shoot out of
here
Uber there's some similarities between
opening up an abscess and opening up a
hematoma you have fluid that runs out
and they both are rewarding because you
can visually see something everywhere
there's a lot of dead space so we need
to do is reduce that Dead Space tighten
it down and we put suture through it to
adhere back down to the cartilage can't
you all right we'll be out in a few
minutes we'll have a brand new ear here
they might start a new look everybody's
gonna be jealous it might say a few
little cats coming here yeah yeah a lot
of cats come in here they're gonna say I
want one yet
let's get a little bandage on there all
right we got the hematoma repaired got
it all bad and stuff we want to hold
this ear down because we don't want
Cliff still shaking the head and causing
issues after surgery everything should
be great and I expect 100 full recovery
how cute is he oh a little bandage on
his head yeah oh man he's nervous about
me
yeah so everything went well got that
ear drained and we have stitches in
there okay we're gonna have medication
going in here oh I know it's cold baby
and then just kind of massage it and
it'll be a lot easier when this wrap
come off okay we definitely want to
shake our head now who put that stuff in
our ears I feel relieved it was really
nerve-wracking because he is 13 years
old and he's just sitting there waiting
by that phone until you get that call
that he's okay he's wrapped up looking a
little crazy but he seems ready to go
home and I just can't wait to get him
home you mad I know I would be mad too
look at you I'm actually terrified right
now what's up you good I'm good how are
you come on tell me about Tonto so he's
like six to eight years old we've had
him for a long time his whole right eye
is just completely swollen and he does
not feel good we ran out of mealworms
and my brother [ __ ] fishing crickets
he got a bruises in his mouth and
everything
good boy my left right gecko Tonto he
has a really bad infection on his right
eye and it's just really badly swollen I
cried when I saw him because he's so
small and this is such a large thing on
his eye I'm worried that he's dying if
he doesn't come out okay today it's
gonna be really really hard his eye was
like leaking pus last night I think he's
in pain yeah it's pretty serious I'll be
back okay thank you this plus is
actually leaking on to Tonto's eyes
which tell me that this thing is really
on a lot of pressure and calling some
pain this plus actually can get in the
bloodstream and cause septicemia which
is infection within the blood which
could possibly come favor
give me a kid to open this is gobs and
Blades this is a major thing that has to
be fixed immediately we need to cut open
Tonto pronto
ah boy we got puss coming out of the
island abscess is typically getting
occur in geckos many ways they can
scratch their eyes it could be a diet
change or it could be feeding live food
those live foods are actually trying to
get away from the geckos so sometimes
they'll scratch it as well can you open
eye pretty rough shape ain't you you got
a painful gecko here there's such a big
abscess that's starting to Ooze from the
eye Sarah can I get a warm whip paper
towel I just want to clean this up a bit
go give me some terramycin to put on
this eye to protect this eye while I do
this let me just kind of wipe it in
there I know but you gotta protect that
eye get my blade open that's something
all right buddy let's get this off your
face just hold still for me anesthesia
with reptiles and lizards there's a
chance that may not wake up but I can do
this procedure really quick when I'm
looking for my actual spot the Lance to
remove this big old pus pocket I'm
really really delicate because the wrong
move and I could actually less this
gecko's eye or hit some parts of the
brain so I have to be really really
precise and really really delicate
you got it DOC
good boy oh man this is a lot of puss
just like squeezing toothpaste out of a
tube no the last little bit here you
look decent that ought to feel a whole
lot better buddy I can't believe how
much pus was in there you probably only
got this out here you probably wouldn't
die
I'm looking at like the size of his head
and what you pulled up that's like he
popping up is it like this big on my
head a huge one right
you looking like a normal gecko look at
that Tonto's head it's a completely
different shape now all of the swelling
has gone down and all of that cottage
cheese abscess stuff is totally removed
huh world look a lot better now yeah it
definitely looks better yeah Toto is
going to get some pain medicine and some
antibiotics and in no time tone should
be back to itself in a hundred percent
hey come on over look a little different
yeah he looks a lot better sorry I'm
gonna cry
I can tell this only really really has a
great deal of affection for Tonto it's
always great to see that human animal
Bond and see people just shoulder they
really love the animal and a super
appreciative and I'm very appreciative
to be a part of that process
Ed it was bad this is what came up oh my
God thank you so much it's all good all
good thank you no problem all right I'll
let you hold them and I'll be in there
with the antibiotics okay but it looks a
lot better it looks a lot better thank
you when they brought me back and showed
me like what came out of him it was
disgusting it was so gross guy cried
when I was back there because I was just
so glad that it's not in there anymore I
knew looking at it yesterday that it was
going to be bad when I brought him in
but I'm just really glad that Dr Hodges
was able to get it out and that he'll be
okay I know sweet boy
foreign
[Music]
after some in-flight issues Milkshake
the parakeet is in need of repair
hello how y'all doing good how are you
I'm doing tremendous how you doing young
man can you hit me with your earphones
on I got a thumbs up everything good
what we got going today milkshake
milkshake because he's one so he's a
vanilla milkshake
so what's going on he was trying to fly
and get a little hard so we wanted to
bring him in okay our parakeet milkshake
was flying and fell and injured his
underbelly we're just hoping that he
doesn't need stitches or have any other
type of procedures I'm very concerned
about milkshake he is my friend and he's
more than a friend he's my family member
and we love him it wasn't like bleeding
really bad it was just exposed okay
I know it's okay it's got like a little
heart here with a little scary I need to
clean up there okay we may have to get a
few feathers so we can see it a little
bit better it's okay it's okay all right
all right hey it's okay feisty milkshake
look and I know we have a scab here but
birds have feathers it's not as easy as
dogs and cats so we can just shave the
area and get a good visual we need to
soften these feathers up using an
antiseptic chlorhexidine and delicately
pluck each feather to remove them so
that we couldn't see what's going on
it's okay I know I don't know is it
bruised all the way up there oh Jordan
holy you see what we're working with yet
all right yeah well it's got a little
hold on
okay so definitely to close that up
he has a laceration right on the end of
his abdominal area this wound is worse
than we anticipated my fear is if we
don't get stitches in there and get this
thing closed up bacterial we have Aid on
the skin they can get an infection and
this bird is not that big you know
anything like infection on birds can be
detrimental
stuff real quick
we had to relax them a little bit and we
may have to kind of put him in the
chamber for a second and see if we can
get a stitch in there all right sweetie
we're going to give out of stage we're
going to do is just put it in the gas
chamber anytime we're dealing with birds
we're always a little bit nervous
because these guys can handle anesthesia
a little bit different really depending
on the bird we're going to be as
cautious as we can and try to relax and
get these stitches in he's going down
quick all right let's see if we get here
the other one was micro surgery this is
micro surgery
put your glasses on for this one didn't
you oh Ain't No Doubt these are some
small stuff obviously this bird's just a
little guy and the wound is there is
actually large for the size of the bird
but for a guy like me sometimes vision
is the issue so we definitely need to
put the glasses on because one wrong
move milkshake will be in trouble that's
one stitch down you might close it one
stitch I think we're gonna take two more
I wish it was an extra large milkshake
right now see if we can get one more in
there almost there extra time buddy
I cut them short so you don't mess with
them yeah all right let's wake this baby
up
hey good job milkshake and don't be mad
with everybody here when you wake up we
have to put a couple of sutures in there
to close that area up but it closed up
real well now we just have to make sure
our milkshake doesn't get to it and try
to open it back up but it should be
healed up in a few days I'm gonna get on
some antibiotics here but I expect full
recovery all right milkshake let's head
on in bro got your baby back
look at that milkshake is all back here
we got a couple stitches in there okay
okay so far it's doing good he's not
messing with him yeah so if you see him
doing you have to say bad bad bad
milkshake don't do that okay don't buy
it's okay you're like I remember you
and we got some medication we sent at
home one is an antibiotic one is a um
pain medication okay okay not a lot of
people in this area have
for birds that
says but it's worth it to make sure that
he's okay he takes his medicine about
like y'all do today
[Music]
could your baby going back home all
right overall it was a great experience
and hopefully our next visit won't be as
exciting milkshake will have to take it
easy for a while and finally need to
stick to some more cuddling time I'm so
happy that milkshake's gonna be okay
thank you
[Applause]
I love it all right got Clips back today
Clips the cat is all ears to hear if
he's made any progress since Dr Ferguson
drained his hematoma we're gonna take a
look at this ear as well as checking 50
stitches already come out I brought
Clips back he's doing a lot better but
he's frustrated he keeps forgetting he
can't go through the kitty door with the
cone on so I'm hoping that everything
will be okay and I can take this cone
off and he can get back to normal oh
that's good yeah looking pretty good
right there it's adhered now those
stitches are ready to be removed all
right well let's take a look in these
ears and see if we need to do some more
cleaning
so we need to flush them out a little
bit but the year itself you see it looks
wider
which is a good thing it is not quite as
red as it was last time good we're gonna
do a cup then we're gonna flush these
ears out and take these stitches out all
right good deal come on clipsy this
hematoma look great in the ear itself
there's still a little bit of
inflammation in there so we want to take
this baby in the back and flush these
ears out I'm sure that after three or
four more days this infection will be
gone all right you ready for your ear
cleaning oh you want to shake hold on
what you're holding for a door ear wax
on me you
I don't know where to stand I hear 22
years of experience
I'm gonna learn a little something 20
plus years
all right we got those ears cleaned out
okay okay everything looks good and it's
healed up we should be about 100 in
three or four days and everything should
be great okay okay gonna go in
there
they're almost cleared up so this is
almost over I'm just waiting for
everything to get back to normal we were
really concerned with Clips being so old
that this was something that had taken
him down but it hasn't so I'm just
really really grateful let's go you
ready to go home
that's that dog that had a big tumor
that you took off Roscoe we took it off
he recovered really well unfortunately
he's the pathology show that his
malignant oh man but we did
vaccine treatments by using the tumor
cells itself it slows down those cancer
cells technology has really allowed us
to be able to save animals they live
longer it's amazing what we can do now
yeah man he's doing really well don't
act like you don't see me
there's too much causing bro so a lot of
breathing issues and he just was not
himself but since he's had the tumor
removed his breathing has improved and
he's enjoying a lot of time with his
brother Jojo go get it Jojo
the vaccine treatment seemed to work I
want to thank Dr Hodges and everyone at
Critter Fixer for giving us the
opportunity to hand the vaccine and
we're just going to continue to take
good care of him and enjoy anytime we
have with Roscoe
[Music]
[Music]